سيده الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه الموقر انه
فخر ان اقف امامكم اليوم وبالنيابه عن
دولتي امثل دوله اسرائيل ان سوف اتحدث عن
الشروط
خطري الضرر الواقع والحاح هذا الشرط
الثالث بكل تاكيد يعتمد على البندين الذين
ذكر سابقا بروفيسور شو والسيده رضوان قد
اظهر بان الصراطات التي قدمتها جهه
الادعاء لا توفر ظاهره وجايه واساس
للاختصاص القضائي كما تحدث اظهروا بان
الحقوق التي تحدث عنها مقدمه الطلب لا
يمكن اعتبارها ايضا قابله للتطبيق
و ان التداعيات التي يمكن جبرها في هذه
الحاله امامنا وفي هذه القضيه
كانت تتعلق بالحقوق بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه ومجددا هذا لا يعني بان الوضع
الانساني ناتج عن الصراع المسلح وليس وضعا
خطيرا جدا المدنيين قد تضرروا بشكل كبير
من الاعمال العدائيه التي بدات بها حماسه
واستراتيجيتها
الممنهجه لشن حربها من تحت و من بين البنى
التحتيه المدنيه وما عرض المدنيين للخطر
وقد سبب بذلك سبب بذلك معاناه كبيره وقد
بدلت اسرائيل ولا تزال تبدل جهد كبير من
اجل تخفيف المعاناه في ظروف صعبه
جدا وبهذا الصدد الحقائق التي
قدمتها الجهه الادعاء هي من طرف واحد
والدعوه
والطلب كان من 48 صفحه ولكنهم لم يكون فيه
اي ذكر لل 148 صفحه ولكنها لم تتطرق
للجهود الاسرائيليه وايضا الاطراف الدوليه
من اجل تحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه مجددا لم
نسمع اي شيء من جهه الادعاء حول هذا الامر
بالامس ولكن هذا معطن اساسي في الدعوه
المقدمه امامكم وكما حدث ذرت السيده رجوان
هذا يضح ايه نيه لوج وجود اباده جماعيه
وفي يتعلق بالاشتراط الثالث الذي تطرقنا
له في الدعوه سيدتي الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه
المقرون نحن نعرف من الدعوه بان سلطه
المحكمه لفرض التدابير المؤقته سوف تمارسه
فقط في ظروف استثنائيه فقط وينبغي ان يكون
هنالك وكما قلت ان يكون هنالك خطر محدق
وان هنالك ضرر لا يمكن جبره مرتبط
بالحقوق المنظوره امام المح كمه حتى تتخذ
قرارها ان قراركم في قضيه
ميانمار والتي تم فيها ايضا تفعيل اتفاقيه
اباده جماعيه تشير بان تبني القرار يعود
الى تدابير
واضحه تاكد وتضمن الحقوق حقوق
المجموعه المتعرض لذلك بالوجود وكان هنالك
طبعا ولكن لم يتم هنالك اثبات مساله
الالحاح والضروره ومثل هذه التدابير
التي اتخذتها اسرائيل
والتي سهلت مزيد ومزيد من المساعدات
الانسانيه لمن هم بحاجه ماس له من الناس
في قطاع غزه هذه الخطوات لم تتزايد فقط
لتتماشى مع الاوضاع المتطوره على الارض
هنالك محاولات مستمره لتقليل الضرر على
المدنيين وهذه
الجهد كان لها نتيجه واثر في الاسبوع
الماضي على دير الذكر بمساعده برنامج
الغذاء
العالمي تم
زياده القدره على انتاج اكثر من مليون غيب
خبز في اليوم برنامج
الغذاء ايضا اثبت بانه ان تزويد الطحين
والسكر والشعير لا يزال مستمرا حتى تستعيد
تفتح يتم اعاده فتح مزيد من المخابز و
تمكين توفير الغذائ لالاف من العائلات
ومنذ ايضا ذكر مقدم الطلب بالامس بان عدد
الشاحنات التي تدخل الى غزه في اليوم الذي
سبق وما بعد الحرب المعدل الحقيقي لعدد
الشاحنات التي تحمل طعاما بشكل محدد هو 70
شاحنه باليوم قبل الحرب و19 شاحنات يوميا
في الاسبوعين الماضيين كل هذه المعلومات
تستطيعون ان تجدونها في الملفات بين يديكم
وايضا الوصول الى مياه الشرب كانت ايضا
اولويه وماك هو الحال مع امدادات الغذاء
لا يوجد هنالك ايه قيود على مقدار المياه
التي تدخل الى قطاع غزه ان اسرائيل مستمره
في تزويد غزه بالمياه عبر
انبوبين وهي تمكن ايصال ايضا المياه
المعباه وبكميات كبيره
وهي تصلح وتوسع البنى التحتيه للمياه
تضررت بسبب عمليه القتال وبالاضافه الى
انبيب المياه ادخال ايصال المياه الى جنوب
غزه من مصر بدا العمل عليه منذ اسابيع
قليله امكانيه ايضا الوصول الى الخدمات
الطب والمواد الطبيه ايضا في تزايد
اسرائيل حتى اللحظه قامت بتمكين انشاء
اربعه مستشفيات ميدانيه و مستشفيين عائمين
وانشاء مستشفي اخرين هو ايضا قيد العمل
اسرائيلي
تسهل دخول فرق طبيه الى غزه وايضا
اللقاحات بما في ذلك وبالتعاون مع
اليونسف وال المرضى
والمصابين تم اجلائهم عبر معبر رفاح الى
مصر والى الامارات العربيه والى تركيا
والى قطر والى
الاردن وايضا معدات الشتاء ايضا تم
تزويدها ان الايصال المستمر لوقود الوقود
ووقود والغاز الطبخ يتم تسيله ايضا وفقا
للبيانات الرسميه مجددا وهي موجوده في
الملفات امامكم منذ الثامن من ديسمبر
مقدار الوقود الذي دخل غزه قد تضاعف
وحاليا يصل الى
188 الف لترا لتر في اليوم هذه
مقدار استهدفته الامم المتحده او حددت
الامم المتحده بنفسها هو منذ 21 من ديسمبر
مقدار غاز الطبخ الذي دخل الى غزه ايضا قد
تضاعف والان وصل الى معدل 90 طنا باليوم
الواحد ان تفاصيل من هذا النوع وال متعلقه
بالمساعدات وجهود الانسانيه المستمره يتم
تحديثها في كل يوم وعلى موقع باللغه
الانجليزيه محدد لوحده الكوج وهي وحده في
الدفاع ووحده في وزاره الدفاع تراقب ايضا
الوضع
الانساني عندما يتم تحديد احتياجات ملحه
يتم
تنسيق الحلول في وقت قريب جهود كبيره هي
يتم استثمارها
في القضاء
على العوائق ولتمكين توصيل المساعدات
الانسانيه هذا طبعا ناهيكم عن ذكر ان حماس
تحاول طريقته بشكل مستمر وقد سمعتم بان
هنالك غرف عمليات مشتركه تتضمن اسرائيل
ومصر والولايات المتحده الامريكيه والامم
المتحده تعمل بشكل يومي من اجل ان تحل في
انيا المشاكل والصعوبات المتعلقه بالامداد
وايضا اسرائيل تنسق مع وكالات امميه
ومع اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر لتوفير
جميع الاحتياجات في ديسمبر قررت اسرائيل
فتح معبر كرم ابو سالم مع نيه تحسين
وتعزيز ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه المحال المدنيين الفلسطينيه في
غز
وهذا القرار الحكومي ايضا متعلق بفتح
المعبر موجود في ملفات
امامكم هذا من اجل تخفيف الضغوطات على
معبر رفح وتسهيل دخول مقدار اكبر من
المساعدات
اسرائيل ايضا تمكن انزال المساعدات جوا
الى غزه مباشره وايضا مكنت ممرات
مائيه الان يتم بحث ممرات مائيه اخرى مع
دول اخرى سيدتي رئيسه اعضاء المحكمه مجددا
هذه فقط مجرد
امثله ولكنها تظهر بان اسرائيل ومن دون شك
تلبي الاحتياجات القانونيه للخطوات
الضروريه
الموجهه لضمان لادراك وضمان حق المدنيين
الفلسطينيين في غزه في الوجود وهذا عمل
يومي لعديد من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
ووكالات اسرائيليه مختل التاكد من ان هذه
الخطوات واخرها يتم تنفيذها بفعاليه في
وقت هم وعائلاتهم هم لا يزالوا تحت هجوم
مستمر
والعزم و الجهود الانسانيه
المتعدده
وزيا كما بعكس ما ذكرت طالب الدعوه بانه
لا يتم بدل الجهود الكافيه لاص مساعدات
الانسانيه اذا سيدتي الرئيسه اعضاء
المحكمه هنالك عنصران
اضافيان يحتاجون انتباهكم الدقيق وهم ايضا
هذا يشيرون الى ان اشتراط الالحاح لا
يتحقق كما حاول جهات الدعاء ان تقنع به
اولا النطاق وحده الاعمال العدائيه قد
انحدر ايضا ان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال
في الاسبوع الماضي بان القوات الاسرائيليه
سوف تتحول من مرحله العمليات المكثفه ذات
الحده العاليه ل
عمليات من نوع خاص اخر وهذا
البيان كان في مقابله الى
الاعلام الدولي وهو مقدم ايضا كحرس في هذه
المحكمه وفي الثمان من يناير في هذا
الاسبوع الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد اكد بان الحمله العسكريه
الاسرائيليه قد بدات اصلا عمليه التحول
الى قوات بريه اقل وضربات جويه اقل ان
الحرب قد حولت تحولت مرحلتها كما قال وكما
ترون في التبويب 16 باء من الملف كان
هنالك حديث عن مرحله اقل حده من القتال او
اقل كثافه وقد تحدث بشكل محدد على ان
اسرائيل سوف تستمر بتقليل عدد القوات في
غزه وخمسه الويه تتضمن الالاف من الجنود
قد انسحبت من
القطاع الامر
الثاني مجلس
الامن مؤخرا قد تبنى
قرارا لهذا الغرض او الغرض المحدد
لتخفيف المعاناه الانسانيه وبقرار 20 27
20 للق 22 من ديسمبر وهو موجود في التبويب
جي في الملف طالب
المجلس
ال اطلاق الغير مشروط والفوري لجميع
الاسرى وايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بمقادير كبيره مباشره الى
المدنيين الفلسطينين في عبر قطاع غزه
والاكثر تحديدا ايضا المجلس طالب الامين
العام من ان يعين منسقا رفيع المستوى من
اجل انشاء اليه امميه من اجل تسريع
لمساعدات الانسانيه او شحدا الاغاثه
الانسانيه الى غزه وعلى النقيد لما سمعناه
بالامس هذا القرار واقتبس لا يبقى غير
مطبقا انهي الاقتباس المسؤول الرفيع تم
تعيينه وهو وهي قد بدات عملها اصلا
والمجلس لا يزال مشرفا مباشره على المساله
واسرائيل بدورها تعمل مع هذا المنسق وفي
هذا الاسبوع فقط قامت بتنسيق دخول وفد
اممي الى شمال غزه من اجل تقييم الوضع
وتحديد خارطه الاحتياجات للعوده
المستقبليه للمدنيين الفلسطينيين وا اتذكر
وماه على صله في انه في قضيه جي ان سي
وجدت المحكمه بانه لم يكن من الضروريه
الاشاره الى التدابير المؤقته مع
حكومه تظهر ارادتها بالعمل بموجب توصيات
مجلس الامن والمتعلق بالموضوع المنظوري
امام
المحكمه كل هذه التطورات الاخيره تشير
بان الحقائق كما هي قائمه لا تدعو الى مثل
هذا الطلب المطلوب كما تشير الى ان الفرق
ما بين القضيه الحاليه وقضايا سابقه عرضت
عليكم هي واضحه
جدا
واخيرا ان غياب عنصر
الالحاحي هو ايضا جلي عبر الضمانات
المقدمه امامكم اليوم من قبل الوكيل
المشترك لاسرائيل ولا يمكن ان
يكون اوضح من ان اسرائيل تبقى ملتزمه في
كل
الاوقات بالتزاماتها
الدوليه ومن دون الحاجه الىل الذكر بان
هذا يتضمن واجب اسرائيل
كدوله موقعه على اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
ان مقدمه الدعوه يود من المحكمه ان
تقول بانها ان الامر عكس ذلك
وان ولسوء
الحظ الامر يتعرض ايضا مع الاعلان الاحادي
للدول ومن غير المفاجئ ان القضيه
امامكم والضمانات التي مقدمه من اسرائيلي
هي مؤشر بان عدم عدم ضروره التدابير
المؤقته او الاشترا الاحترازيه اي سيده
الرئيسيه الخلاصه هي بان اشتراط الضرر
الغير الذي لا يمكن اصلاحه لا يمكن تحقيقه
في هذه القضيه ان اسرائيل هي ومواطنها هم
من يواجهون خطرا لا يمكن اصلاحه اذا ما تم
منح طلب جنوب افريقيا